i've had the experience
in multiple places i've had it in
portland where you know i try to be
i'm careful how i say things but i try
uh
never to leave a misimpression about
what i actually think is going on so
when people say this
you know this rhetoric about anti-racism
and stuff
i find a way to point out that um i
don't believe that this is anti-racism
and that i'm frightened of what it's
doing
people confess to me all the time right
like in these
interpersonal interactions and
you know they confess oh i am also
frightened of this blah blah blah blah
so there's a lot of stuff going on right
below the surface
just below and you know i'm also hearing
it
not locally here i'm hearing lots of
people
who we know and i will never cough them
up i'm not going to say who but
um people are frequently telling me you
know
i'm contemplating political stuff i
never would have thought before
because you know this is really scary
and so anyway because look at what's
coming out of the executive branch
right right this the stuff that's coming
out of the executive branch from a guy
who these people you're talking about
don't have any respect for
yeah now he's doing things that are
necessary and respectable
well if you uh just use the following
generating function
you and i have both said versions of
trump is a political genius
right you've called him a savant yeah
okay he's a political genius i don't
think he's ideological
no right in no way the idea that he's
going to bring fascism down like no he's
a narcissist well actually
he might bring fascism down if it was a
popular thing to do but i don't think
it's
not because he's into fascism right and
the fact is if
if you know if some kind of uh
reasonable or at least functional
leftism was the thing he might be
showing up on that side
he's self-interested and he's riding
these waves so here's the point
you've got a huge number of people
anybody who's got any reason left to
them at all
is knows that something has to halt the
march of critical race theory and all of
its outgrowths right we cannot have
people confronting each other
in a cafe and have nothing uh happen
right you cannot have people targeting
uh
members of some mainstream political
movement in the middle of the street and
shooting them
right so somebody has to do something
and trump is detecting hey there's a
vast constituency out there that wants
something
done and isn't feeling like they can say
so yeah so now he's tapping into it of
course
right so you should expect to do it and
here's the thing
uh let's put unity aside for a second i
do believe unity is vastly more possible
than people give it credit for
and the longer the democratic party
refuses to acknowledge what's going on
and
adds fuel to the fire the greater the
chances of something unusual like unity
working
become but if we take unity out of the
picture for a second
um i think trump is going to win
uh handily and this is before we even
get to the debates and there's a
question
yeah the democrats have given us
effectively
um a scarecrow in place of a candidate
right they've given us something that
looks takes human form but is not really
capable of delivering
on that wasn't very nice it's not very
nice on the other hand
why are people angry at me for saying
such things shouldn't they be
angry at the democratic party for
delivering this
absolutely yes so i don't know how they
get the scarecrow through the debate
maybe no you know maybe they've got a
plan but um i don't think it's going to
work
so and we're not prepared for this but
didn't you tell me that pelosi
said something to the effect of well
biden
shouldn't legitimize trump by agreeing
to debate him
like shouldn't legitimize the sitting
president by agreeing to debate him is
that not an out for someone who can't
debate or you know if if it's not i've
never heard one
it was beautiful you can imagine the
dumb ships in the democratic party who
are responsible for political strategy
getting together and saying all right
here's what we're going to do nancy
you're going to tell you're going to
tell biden that he
shouldn't debate so as not to legitimize
trump because nobody wants trump
legitimized
right and then biden will be able to say
oh no i'm debating him so that'll make
him look strong
oh this is great you could just imagine
them setting that plan
up right and you know it went off with a
whimper
and everybody saw through it right so
anyway okay
at what point are you going to
acknowledge that we have handed
the responsibility for recapturing the
white house
to a bunch of people whose understanding
of this whole process is that of a third
grader
right and they've blown it quite
predictably and the clock is ticking and
nobody's got a plan b
like at some point with the ring
they're totally waiting for their snack
yeah
yeah political geniuses in the
democratic party and see a bunch of
juice boxes and send them on their way
totally oh i love it i love it um
yeah why didn't we think of that juice
box we probably could have settled this
if we you know
came up with good notes this one also
wants juice boxes
all right where are we um so we are uh
how how far
are we in zach
okay um so um what
where where would you like to go we
wanted to uh they're a couple so on this
my prediction and by the way i've gotten
one prediction very wrong here and
nobody's taken me to task for it which i
think means they must be
somebody's holding it in reserve what is
it i predicted that biden wasn't going
to get the nomination
i was wrong about that okay um no big
deal i've been right about a lot of
stuff but
okay yeah that one was uh that they were
going to
they were going to pull it somehow last
minute yeah which you know
after i predicted it i thought that's
not right i think
it's still likely but it'd be after the
nomination because then that gives the
dnc the ability to
swap rather than if you do it before the
convention then
technically the delegates have the
opportunity to do something else which
doesn't sound like the dnc so probably i
shouldn't have
made that prediction i still think the
model is right i still think
they know that he's a placeholder for
either party rule or
you know kamala harris is party rule
incarnate or whatever their
plan is but um but anyway i got it wrong
but anyway i'm predicting here trump is
going to win by a large margin
the reason is obvious because the fact
of people not being able to say what
they think
causes noise in the polling that you
can't
overcome right people people will hold
their nose
like many of them did in 2016 and say i
don't like the guy personally and i
don't trust him over in this space
uh you know over in leadership space uh
but
but he's actually willing to do some of
the things that need to be done
and the democrats don't seem willing to
do so right except that
by setting this in motion they're now
setting us up for
the question we still can't answer right
turned out the guy wasn't hitler
he was hitler we'd know it by now right
but okay not an ideologue
what happens when you elect the guy for
his second term
and he doesn't face another election now
i don't think
anything hitlerian is the answer here
but the point is
we are going to find out if this if i'm
right about what's going to happen
and unity 2020 does not manage to pull
it out which i still
believe is a possibility and we can talk
more about that but if trump
uh is um sworn in again
then we're going to find out what trump
with the gloves off looks like right
and that uh i think
is a failure mode waiting to happen that
this is a disaster that is going to feed
the crazed left many of the things that
it's going to need to fashion some story
that's going to justify it's becoming
even more unhinged
and anyway it's a as as his election in
2016 did
yeah frankly right i mean this the
polarization
uh was already well underway before
trump appeared on the scene whenever he
first began to run but certainly
the both the election and then the
inauguration
were step functions in the
in the depravity of the techniques used
by
the would-be activists on the left yeah
now we can hope that something else
would unfold
we can hope that um in light of not
having to face another election
that trump might begin to think about um
legacy yeah about uh confounding
his critics by
doing unifying things and in fact going
up against critical race theory
uh is such a thing i don't really expect
this because for one thing
those who do the writing of history have
announced that effectively there's
nothing that he could do that they would
record as positive
so at some level they are
disincentivizing his behaving in our
collective interest
yep so it's a disaster a disaster
waiting to happen of course
[Music]
you